ce n'est pas par honte mais plutôt pour
des considérations professionnelles
qu'elle a demandé de raconter
anonymement ce qu'elle a vécu quand elle
avait 17 ans
quand
c'est pour toi que tu connais une bonne
situation
tu restes
après avoir appris qu'elle était
enceinte
une solution c'est donc imposer
l'avortement l'obstacle que moi j'ai eu
c'était d'avoir accès justement à ces
services là n'étaient pas disponibles
dans la région j'ai dû aller faire deux
heures de route pour le rand a battu
c'était de zara les deux heures de
retour qui a duré prise onze ans plus
tard le gouvernement du nouveau
brunswick ne finance toujours que les
avortements pratiqués dans trois
hôpitaux celui de bathurst et les deux
qui se trouve à moncton ce taux devrait
pouvoir
on est désolé mais c'est pas un droit
qui est accessible ses parts au service
accessible quand ça nous coûte de
l'argent que ça nous coûte du temps
cette militante rochois dénonce
d'ailleurs le fait que la province reste
la seule à ne pas financer les
avortements sont pratiqués en dehors du
cadre hospitalier notre gouvernement va
jamais reculer dans la défense
des droits des femmes une frustration
partagée par le gouvernement trudeau
selon qui ce refus du nouveau brunswick
va à l'encontre de ses obligations en
matière de santé on est en train de
financer des études pour regarder la
réalité de l'accès conseil n'est pas
pareil partout au pays et donc nous
sommes en train de regarder exactement
ce qu'on peut et doit faire de plus pour
assurer que toutes les femmes ont ce
libre choix à travers le pays
pour ces députés de l'opposition les
libéraux en du rattrapage à faire en la
matière sous fait le recensement de tout
ce qui était fait depuis ce temps pour
améliorer l'accessibilité et la sécurité
aux femmes qui souhaitent se prévaloir
de ce choix là vous allez arriver à
quelque chose de complètement nul donc
un cadre à l'endroit de juridiction qui
sont plus restrictives je le
comprendrais mais il faut pas que ça
vienne s'ingérer dans ce que sont des
compétences des provinces ou assurément
mais pour celles qui l'ont vécu ce n'est
pas une question politique
le fait d'avoir
des choix quant à son compte des
décisions qui sont prises ce service qui
devrait être partout mais plutôt une
question dignité ici mathieu papillon
radio-canada moncton